oh there's a trailer for a new
Transformers movie so hey gotta talk
about that I don't have to but since
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen was
the start of my YouTube world I want it
before we get into it I'm gonna preface
this entire video with its teaser
trailer I know that anything could
happen in the movie in this trailers not
going to show as much I've said this
trailer has some interesting issues in
it because it was like oh it's not
season King Arthur and you feel like the
King Arthur thing is just going to be
the vagus I had back in the day back
when King Arthur made a deal with
Optimus Primal might be I don't know now
Optimus Prime is floating in space
Optimus Prime fighting bumblebee all I
know is I think Unicron is about to eat
the moon until further notice I'm
treating that as Unicron that is the
coolest shot in the trailer probably
should save the coolest shot in the
trailer for last the coolest shot hands
down in the trailer is that scene where
you see that thing eating the moon that
just looks big that's just that's a very
good representation of size remember in
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen where
they had the Devastator on a pyramid and
99% of the population of the earth has
never seen the pyramids if we don't know
how big they are thus we don't know how
big Devastator is we know the moon is
big so that thing is big I love this
effect Optimus Prime is like floating in
space and Anthony Hopkins is Optimus
Prime has left us is that way dudes like
I'm out of here
I think earth was better after that Josh
Duhamel is back and he in Mark Wahlberg
have classic transformers trailer
dialogue which is we can't do that thing
we guys are the thing okay we can't do X
we got to do X
they got Dinobots again Dinobots are
gonna be back I don't know why it was
such an irritant to me in transformers
what was the fourth line in the last
Transformers film they never actually
call Grimlock Grimlock I want to hear
their names man I want to hear Grimlock
slag sludge snarl swoop give me their
names cuz they have name ideas not smart
by any means Grimlock is pretty dumb
it's like Siri
Grimlock but he's still he's sent to him
saying Optimus Prime is fighting
bumblebee which may coincide with like
this we'll see where he just face slams
bumblebee at the end he's like forgive
me and he stabs bumblebee mic coincide
with that see where bumblebee looks like
he's dying that would be a bummer of
Optimus Prime kills bumblebee maybe
Unicron slug I'm gonna make a new
Optimus Prime since Optimus Prime's up
there floating in his paradise world
because he left earth for it looks fun
maybe this Optimus Prime
is the new Galvatron I don't know all I
know is there's a new Transformers movie
coming out at this point I can't get
pumped for when I saw the first
Transformers movie I was like oh yeah
bring on this franchises alright do you
fix a few things here and there and you
can have something great in the end it
looks like just what we've seen in
transformers robots and robots and that
sound that's an I feel like the
Transformers movies at this point are
like the abusive boyfriend and we are
the girlfriend the first ones like
alright yeah well except that one flaw I
Iike yeah I'm enjoying this second what
happens like break up third one was
better than the last one so it's like
alright I'll give you another chance
fourth one was worst I was like break up
and now this franchise is asking for me
to take it back I can't I can't give
that many chances to garbage I just
can't I can't promise much but I can
promise you this if the movie is somehow
great the review will be a lot of fun to
film if the movie is [ __ ] horrible
the review will be a lot of fun to film
so hey man whatever happens commit to
either side great or [ __ ] so
transformers the last night teaser
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it ever you thought comment
below let me know the funny if you mix
the titles of Transformers Dark of the
Moon and transformers the last night you
come up with Transformers The Dark
Knight under sign and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]